it serves all sort of prank stories on
the sofa I doubt anyone can top Kate
Beckinsale's this is such a genius prank
and I sort of hate asking you to tell us
because I would so like to do it to
someone yeah and this will spoil it go
okay it was in a very impromptu one
because I'd been if somebody falls
asleep next to me it's dangerous because
I like to glue beards to them or draw
tattoos or whatever it is
pirates the Carribean beard all that and
I'd run out of things like that and and
yet I was still after the rush of doing
it I got into bed and I said I think
I've got a little you know one of those
chocolates that that you get by the bed
oh yeah no and I thought how funny would
it be if I just tucked it in between the
person's buttocks all their City and it
was really funny isn't that so good
yeah and it just sort of came very
organically can I have my eyes fell on
the chocolate and I kind of did that oh
I see the sleeping bottom here and then
I thought I'm just gonna do it and I
talked to didn't I thought maybe I'd get
in trouble in the morning but it was a
very fortuitous day because this was the
morning where the person was in a
terrible rush and just went straight
into the pants and the trousers and
straight to work so so halfway through
the day at work there was there another
kind of a pervert scuttled backwards to
live and then the horror horror I've
done this without even feeling it
oh it smells so minty I didn't know it's
going to go that far I thought it was
just going to be the morning but it just
sort of unfold so well was it just
sleeping mixed there's surely a friend
of so oh yes oh yes it wasn't as someone
I didn't know did you feel bad no I was
absolutely I loved them dinner but I did
I had no Judy I don't do tea but I
thought I was gonna have the thing in
the morning of Oh Kate you put chocolate
in my piece of chocolate it wasn't it
wasn't a Toblerone
that's not
mr. the persons did the was it but did
other people notice this disturbed by
their up it you know I know but it was
only for their benefit of their there it
was their shock not others who was but
who were behind them to see the results
of their because they had on trousers
and pants but it might have been muzzled
on the top they placed it very carefully
century essentially potential
presidential place we don't fall out
tonight the thing about chocolate is in
the night between a pair of buttocks
it's going to just sort of soften our
yeah you know it was it nutty
it is stopping job on it with that you
stretch yourself and now you're thinking
maybe
when he showed some chocolate in my ass
so we have to drive from London to
Blackpool in those no no yes yes so
there's there's some episodes that maybe
they're like no is great but you're sort
of not really on very much are you